[音楽]
よろしくお願いします
さっき部活の後に後輩にレッドブルを
もらって翼授けてもらったので今日は
頑張ろうと思います
僕の自己紹介からしようと思います僕は
ここの普通から帰って今曲の2年生ですで
さっき言った通り部活は競争部の東京で
やっていて
趣味はアフリカとかランニングだったりし
ます今まで3つのアプリを作ってきました
で最近作った一番最近作ったアプリが
マネージーという陸上の練習記録管理
アプリでどっかにその飛んでるんですけど
それくらいですけどそのくんと一緒に作り
ましたこれはどんなアプリか軽く説明する
と
陸上だと距離とかタイムとかを記録したい
と思うんですけどそれをこういう風に記録
できたりそれを確認できたりとかその記録
のもとにこのようにグラフで分析できたり
するような人のアプリを作りました
さて今日のこのテッドテレックスのトーク
のためにアンケートを皆さんに取りました
受講生を始めた66名の方に協力いただい
てアンケートとりましたぜひ皆さんも一緒
に考えてみてくださいではまず1問目です
皆さん
普段うまく使ってますかこれも当たり前で
みんな100%の人が使っているという
ことでございました
では普段アプリを使っていて不満に思った
ことがある人は送られたでしょうか
これも
88%すごい多くの人が普段Apple
使っていて思っているん
ですではこんな風に不満を感じた人がどれ
くらいアプリに対してレビューを書いたり
するなどアクションを起こしている
でしょうか
これがなんとたったの20%だけなんです
多くの人がアプリに対して不満を持ってる
にもかかわらず何のアクションも起こして
いないのはなぜなんでしょうか
これはいくつかの理由がもちろん考えられ
ます今ただただめんどくさいとか
意見を見ることそんな不安じゃないけどね
みたいな人もいると思います
ここで一つ面白いアンケート結果があり
ます
アプリの仕組みどうやって作られているか
その仕組みを調べたことがある人はどの
くらいいるん
これがさらに減って18%だけなん
です
アプリのアプリに対してアクションを
起こさない一番の理由が僕はアプリの
仕組みを知らないからであるという風に
考えましたどんなプロセスで誰がどうやっ
て作っているのかを知らないのに
適切なリフォームなど使用することさえも
できないわけです
プログラミングとかアプリとか言うと皆
さんこんな風な印象があるんじゃない
でしょうか
そうですこのコードですね皆さんはと思っ
た人今僕の予想通りの感想なんですけど
そう
難しくて学ぶ気も起きないですでもアプリ
とかプログラミングと呼ばれるとこういう
印象ばかりありますが実はアプリってこれ
だけじゃないんです
皆さん日頃からアプリを使っている上で
その仕組みは最低限理解すべきだという
ふうに思いませんか
ということで今回はアプリ開発から学ぶ
ものの仕組みを知る大切さについて話して
いこうと思います
まず一つのアプリというのはどのように
できているのか皆さんご存知でしょうか
ざっと上げてみるとこんな感じですでも
いっぱいだとよくわからないと思うので
今回は先ほど紹介したマネージがどうやっ
てできたのかに
沿って少し話していこうと思います
まずは手順1はどんなアプリを作るか
考えるこれがないとアプリは出来上がり
ません
アプリを作る上で重要なのはまず財布系の
アプリを作って
ターゲットを誰の絞ってそしてどんな特徴
を持ったアプリにするかですアプリは
世の中にたくさんあるので
特徴を持ったアプリを作らないと誰も使っ
てくれません
僕は日頃から競争部に入っていて
練習記録がしづらいという悩みがあったの
でそれを掛け合わせて
掛け合わせて部活で使える練習の記録
アプリを作ろうと考えました
さてこれでアプリの方向性がだいたい
決まりました次は機能考えていきます
機能の考えでアプリには必ず2つの機能が
ありますそれは
必須の機能と
プラスアルファの機能です
これも陸上部アプリに当てはめて考えて
みると例えば
必須の機能だったらメニューは絶対記録
できないとアプリとしてないといけません
あとそれを確認できる機能ももちろん必要
です
では逆にプラスアルファの機能としては
より細かい情報足の痛みだったりとか
細かい情報を記入できたらとても良い
アプリになりますしそれを分析できたら
もっと皆さん使いたいと思っており
こういうふうにようやく具体的な機能が
揃いました
次に画面のデザインを考えます画面
デザインを考えるときはどこで誰が何の
ために使うのかこれを考えていきます
例えばどこで使うのかを考えると屋外で
使う場合は
暗い画面だとよく見えないので明るい画面
にする必要があり
ますでも室内の場合は別に暗い色だって
シックでかっこいいわけ
ですこんな風にどこで誰が何のために使う
のかを考えると自然に
デザインこれでようやく開発前の準備が
整うわけです
いよいよ開発に進んでいきます
そう先ほど考えた画面のデザインのもと
デザイン元に実際にこのように設計をして
いって皆さんももちろんこの画面ですそう
昨日の実装行動を打つという作業に変えて
いき
ます皆さんアプリ開発でこれだけで終わり
じゃないかと思ってる人多いと思いますが
全然これだけで終わりではありません
でデモンストレーションをしていきます
バグの確認はもちろんのことを機能とその
機能本当に必要なのか逆にこういう機能が
あったらいいんじゃないかデザインを邪魔
したりしていきます
すると自然にこのようにデザインや機能に
ついて疑問が湧いていって
仮返す仮完成したその状態を見たからこそ
わかることがいくつか出てきます
その県道を重ねた結果のものを実際に修正
してそれをまた加熱それで完成した作品を
また見てでまた検討してそれを何度も何度
も繰り返してようやく一つのアプリが
出来上がるわけです
さてここまでアプリを一つが出来上がる
流れを見てきましたがこんな感じですね
これを実は大きく4つに分けることが
できるんですそれは
まずどんなアプリを作るか考える法案
そしてその考えたものをもとに実際に形に
落としていく開発
して仮完成したものをもとに修正を加えて
いてようやく感染に結びつけていく
わけですさて突然ですがこれを皆さんが
作文を書くプロセスと全く一緒なのです
というのも皆さんは作文を書くときに
どんなことを書こうかとまず考えます
で考えたらあとは手を動かすだけ開発し
ます
そして出来上がったものをもとに
推敲と呼ばれる修正作業を行って一つの
作文として
完成していくわけです
そう全てのものはこの仕組みで実はできて
いるんです
皆さんがそしてここで今日の問題に戻り
ます
学芸開発から学ぶものの仕組みを知る大切
さ
皆さんアプリ開発で聞くとついついこの
開発の部分ばかり考えがちな人が多いと
思います
でも開発はたったの1ステップにしか過ぎ
ず
むしろ一番大切なのはこの公安考える部分
なん
です考えられたものをもとに
設計して形にしていくことはちょっとやれ
ば誰でもできますし機会だって全然でき
ます
でもどんなアプリを作るのかどんな作文
書くのかもそうそれを形に考え考えてまず
はその青を出すことっていうのは皆さん
自身しかできないです
このように皆さんはアプリの仕組みを知っ
たことで今アプリ開発が行動が落ちてる
作業だけでないということを今知りました
ね皆さん
なので物の仕組みを知ることでいろんな
知らず嫌いが消していけると僕は思います
皆さんもたくさんの仕組みをしていろんな
ものに対する知らず嫌いを減らしていって
いただければと思いますそれで僕の発表は
ありますありがとうございます